Silicon Valley Bank became the largest
U.S Bank to fail since 2008 and the
second largest U.S Bank to fail ever
here's a look at what happened
[Music]
thank you system is safe
Silicon Valley Bank catered mainly to
tech companies and startups around the
world their services were in high demand
during the pandemic years and money
poured in as consumers spent big on Tech
and Digital Services now when people
deposit money into Banks it doesn't just
sit there the banks take that money and
reinvest it Silicon Valley Bank or svb
for short was taking depositors money
and investing into long-term Securities
like bonds but recently the Federal
Reserve has been hiking interest rates
to try to combat inflation that means
svb's Bond portfolio lost a lot of value
and at the same time as the economy has
gotten worse the tech industry has
slowed down so svb's customers started
drawing on their deposits but the
problem is the bank didn't have enough
money on hand on March 8th svb's parent
company svb Financial Group announced a
2.25 billion dollar share sale after
already selling off Securities from its
portfolio and taking a 1.8 billion
dollar loss that scared svb's customers
and triggered a bank run share prices
plummeted and clients pulled their money
out of svb and quickly by March 10th the
bank unable to pay its customers
collapsed the US government quickly
stepped in and guaranteed all deposits
from svb customers hoping to stop any
effects of svb's collapse from spreading
into the economy svb clientele was
almost exclusively tech companies and
Venture Capital backed startups so at
the moment experts don't expect issues
from svb's collapse to affect other
Banks
[Music]